[Applauso]
ognuno di noi vive immerso nella propria
realtà e ogni realtà è differente l'una
dalle altre ma tutte queste realtà hanno
in comune
l'ambiente su cui esse vengono create
l'ambiente dove noi viviamo vivendo in
questo ambiente e creiamo la nostra
realtà ecco che non possiamo più parlare
come pochi anni fa di un ambiente unico
ma oggi parliamo di un ambiente ibrido
un in un ambiente che è diviso tra
quello che ha fisico l'ambiente fisico
sia dove ci muoviamo dove respiriamo
dove ci nutriamo è invece da ambiente
virtuale l'ambiente dove leggiamo dove
comunichiamo dove impariamo e quindi
cambiamo l'ambiente in cui perché no
anche desideriamo guarda che bella
fotografia
vorrei proprio essere la in quel in
quell'ambiente in quel posto ed è molto
curioso almeno secondo il mio personale
del punto di vista notare che noi siamo
esseri fisici nasciamo fisicamente ma
nel momento in cui nasciamo fisicamente
siamo subito inseriti in un ambiente che
è ibrido vediamo magari i nostri
genitori ei nostri conoscenti dialogare
tra di loro con altri oggetti con
oggetti che oggi si chiamano smart phone
o vediamo ancora dei sistemi totalmente
automatici che dialogano tra di loro
dialogano magari per monitorare il
nostro stato ed è un ambiente che non
c'è stato dato è un ambiente che lo
creiamo noi e questo ambiente virtuale
lo creiamo così bene giorno dopo giorno
da desiderano tantissimo ad ogni
telefonata che facciamo ad ogni sms che
inviamo ad ogni like che mettiamo ed è
un sistema un ambiente che è stato
creato però senza un progetto
proviamo pensare nel fisico
nell'ambiente fisico un essere umano
alla necessità di avere una casa e
quindi quello che fa è un progetto
quanti bagni quante camere da letto
se il giardino o il balcone
nell'ambiente invece virtuale
questo progetto non c'è mai stato sono
state soltanto e sempre delle domande
molto e delle risposte a delle domande
molto eterogenee ma non gestite e create
da un unico progetto
ecco perché ad oggi questo ambiente è
profondamente ancora inesplorato e
inesplorato e ahimè molto insicuro
perché è molto insicuro perché appunto
come abbiamo detto manca quel progetto e
lo vediamo tutti i giorni quando per
esempio vediamo nostra figlia correre
dalla madre piuttosto che corre ad
abbracciare un monitor o anche quando
nel momento del bisogno magari perché il
nostro figlio ha paura del buio non
corre a prendere lo smartphone che
potrebbe essere utilizzato anche come
torcia ma contrariamente corre ad
abbracciare la madre o nel caso che
fortunato il padre e e questo è questo
momento che personalmente mi ha mosso e
mi ha insegnato e mi ha chiesto di
dedicare parte della mia vita grande
parte della mia vita alla difesa
sì perché nel mondo fisico
esistono strumenti metodologie persone
che ci difendono giorno dopo giorno ma
nell'ambiente virtuale ancora questo non
è così semplice
non è ancora così ovvio non ci sono
ancora persone non ci sono ancora
strumenti processi e metodologie reali
per difenderci però pensare per esempio
a chi di noi avrà bisogno di un
peacemaker i peace maker ad oggi sono
totalmente connessi non c'è chance non
possiamo scegliere un peacemaker dialoga
attraverso il nostro smartphone col
centro di competenza e questo è un bene
a fantastico perché nel momento in cui
avevo magari bisogno di un intervento il
nostro peacemaker comunicherà
direttamente al centro di competenza
all'ospedale che c'è qualcosa che non va
o ancora meglio nel momento in cui
andiamo dal nostro medico si può fare
uno screening veloce
senza necessariamente farci fare chissà
quali tipologie di esami ecco perché
questa interfaccia nel virtuale se non
utilizzato in un modo consapevole crea
dei problemi per esempio nel 2010 un
gruppo di ricercatori statunitensi hanno
individuato che alcuni dispositivi di
alcune case produttrici e statunitensi
erano vulnerabili alle action
quindi che cosa significa che un
attaccante poteva comodamente con il
proprio smartphone da remoto
ok bluetooth stiamo parlando quindi
poche decine di metri però poteva
riprogrammare il nostro peacemaker ora
senza scendere in casi troppo drastici
l'attaccante aveva la possibilità di
modificare lo stato d'animo più agitato
oppure più calmo della persona della
vittima
ecco come un un l'interfaccia nel
virtuale può avere un grave una grave
conseguenza anche nel nostro reale
oppure proviamo a pensare ai nostri
conti correnti abbiamo portafogli sempre
più piccoli è sempre più leggeri ma
conti correnti con sempre più numeri
proviamo a pensare a quanto è fantastico
questo perché riusciamo a controllare le
transazioni e transazioni bancarie sono
anche più economiche e riusciamo
semplicemente con uno smartphone a
pagare per i nostri beni però cosa può
succedere se un attaccante per esempio
con degli attacchi molto noti ad oggi di
tipologia drivex e riescono a impiantare
un malware all'interno del nostro
browser per prelevare username e
password
ora se la nostra banca non ha sviluppato
non ha altre tipologie di autenticazione
questo è ovvio che può avere un grave
riflesso sul nostro reale in quanto
l'attaccante potrebbe in qualche modo
per levare del denaro dal nostro conto
corrente o ancora proviamo a pensare una
cosa ancora più fantastica più bella che
sono e nuove auto sempre connesse
un'auto connessa e fantastica perché ci
può dare la possibilità di chiamare
aiuto nel momento del bisogno può
decidere in funzione del mio stato di
guida allo stato meteo e ha come solo
per esempio l'estate
mi può suggerire di fare una strada
piuttosto che un'altra nel 2014
alcuni ricercatori hanno individuato
ahimè che estrapolando la sim card che è
presente all'interno di queste
automobili e sempre connesse era
possibile comodamente dal divano di casa
entrare nella stessa rete di tutte
queste macchine e sfruttando alcune
vulnerabilità sono riusciti a entrare
nel centro di intrattenimento dell'auto
e poi con un paio di attacchi
leggermente più complessi sono riusciti
ad eseguire codice cannes
all'interno della macchina il
significato era è che hanno avuto il
controllo il controllo totale
dell'autovettura quindi potevano da
remoto tenere in ostaggio la vittima il
proprietario della casa della
dell'automobile all'interno
dell'automobile e magari chiedere un
riscatto in bitcoin per poter rilasciare
oppure potevano abbassare o eliminare i
fanali le luci in una corsa notturna o
cambiare la mappatura del motore o
eliminare abs a colore un altro
un altro esempio di come l'interfaccia
del virtuale ha delle implicazioni molto
importanti nel reale
proviamo a pensare ancora una volta gli
oggetti domestici
chi di noi non ha un sistema di luci
controllato da remoto o dei sistemi web
che controllano lo stato di produzione
della propria casa o ancora un sistema
per esempio di videosorveglianza di
allarme è un attaccante potrebbe
utilizzare questi strumenti per capire
se all'interno dell'abitazione di apple
non vi è la persona l'attaccato e poi
avere un un'azione effettuare un'azione
nel fisico o ancora e poi vi prometto
questo è l'ultimo un altro esempio è
nella identità personale proviamo a
pensare per un attimo se i politici o
sei grandi l'idea di grandi aziende
iniziano in spontaneamente a comunicare
attraverso social e quindi attraverso
per esempio twitter facebook
proviamo ora ad immaginare è chiaro che
la la percezione che si ha è comunque la
potenza di comunicazione è veramente
elevata ma proviamo a immaginare una
un attaccante che riesce in qualche modo
è impadronirsi di un canale di
comunicazione di questa natura di un per
esempio politico ed effettua al posto di
quella persona una comunicazione non sto
pensando a scenari di guerra ma anche
comunicazioni legislative che cosa può
succedere per intera popolazione
cosa può succedere per intero o gruppo
politico per esempio che vi è che vi
all'interno
ecco tutto questo nasce perché ad oggi
c'è il grande c'è la grande percezione
della protezione noi oggi ci fidiamo di
quello che sta succedendo e di quello
che ci protegge all'interno del virtuale
in questo caso il ciclista sta assumendo
che quel lucchetto non verrà mai
tagliato e quindi dice io mi fido così
tanto di questo lucchetto che mi
allontano perché tanto nel periodo di
tempo che io sto lontano da questo
lucchetto non ci sarà nessuno che ha la
possibilità di tagliarlo e portarmi via
la bicicletta nel digitale questo non
funziona non funziona perché il virtuale
l'ambiente digitale spetta il tempo e
rompe lo spazio che cosa significa che è
un attacco può essere fatto non
necessariamente nello stesso periodo
temporale o ancora chi attacca può
essere fisicamente da un'altra parte
rispetto invece a chi ha la vittima ecco
allora perché bisogna pensare con
un'altra mentalità una mentalità molto
più complessa che è la difesa difendersi
significa capire significa essere certi
che prima o poi qualcuno mi romperà
quell'oggetto essere certi che arriva un
attacco capace di andare a buon fine e
bisogna capire che cosa come rispondere
quindi quali sono i metodi quali sono
gli strumenti da utilizzare
quali sono le metodologie e le persone i
gruppi le comunicazioni com'è che
bisogna fare quando un attacco arriva
e la soluzione principale ad oggi sta
nella collaborazione e risulta evidente
che un essere umano all'interno del
virtuale o del digitale non ha la
capacità da solo di riuscire a bloccare
tutti gli attacchi che ci sono
risulta anche evidente però che neanche
i sistemi totalmente automatici e
riescono a bloccare individuare tutte le
problematiche che ci sono e lo vediamo
su tutti i giornali ma la collaborazione
l'unione tra uomo e macchina avere una
mente umana capace di percepire i
sussurri capace di percepire quei
piccoli rumori che rendono all'attacco
efficace e una macchina un sistema un
sistema informativo informativo
informatizzato un sistema che ha la
possibilità di agire in maniera
tempestiva la collaborazione oggi tra
uomo e macchina è la vera risposta della
difesa perché perché le macchine sono
molto più forti di noi sono molto più
veloci di noi non abbiamo chance sulla
forza computazionale delle macchine sono
anche le macchine quelle artificialmente
intelligenti sono molto molto brave ad
effettuare un tasca dare delle risposte
risposte puntuali sono veramente veloci
e performanti a fare qualsiasi cosa
tra cross correlazione e individuazione
dei grandi rumori ma ricordiamoci una
cosa e ricordiamoci la in maniera molto
forte
e ricordiamoci ha in modo molto precisa
siamo solo noi esseri umani capaci a
porre le domande giuste nel momento
giusto
grazie
[Applauso]